à paris dans le 19e quelques élèves de
confession israélite ont été amenés à
retirer la kippa la kippa et d'un l'un
des objets symboles de la religion juive
c'est une petite calotte que l'on pose
sur sa tête car conformément à la loi
religieuse
il est recommandé de rester toujours
couverts alors gérard beau fils s'est
rendu au lycée hélène boucher mais on en
voit dans la cour des failles de type à
et ça vous dérange pas de toute façon
ils ont leur religion et la foi qui
était comme ça moi je suis pas toubib
récupère ça tout le monde chacun droite
il a un jeu qui savez que normalement
dans les statuts l'école doit être là et
d'ail
oui on doit pas afficher de signes
extérieurs de sa confession
parce que ça vous paraît dépassé comme
nation le temps et aux réformes alors
annoncées négatif pour nous sert à rien
de négatif
il regrette que la direction
d'établissement a demandé d'enlever ses
équipes à ces jeunes gens vous trouvez
ça normal ou pas normal ça dérange
personne chez bras en même temps ils
doivent s'adapter quand jean coutumes du
pays je pense au minimum les français
quand ils vont par exemple dans les pays
arabes et tout ça on leur demande
automatiquement des sports forme et aux
coutumes du pays d'évran faire autant de
français d'accord qui pratiquent leur
religion mais c'est comme ça à petit au
milieu où ils sont environ nement à
l'environnement ils peuvent pratiquer
leur religion entre et puis dans une
enceinte où les religions sont mélangés
son
paul s'adapter
à ne pas montrer leur religion forcément
pas
java pourquoi
[Musique]